it's not just airflow over the wing that
makes the airplane fly it's money flow
over the wing they've got to come
together and that can be success for
everybody involved yeah i mean listen
again union spokesperson who supports
capitalism gotta love it and we had
boots on the ground knowledge that this
virus was was going like crazy over
there and we did not want to be the
vessel that transmitted that virus back
here into the u.s how tougher is it
today
for a person to
do another uh
9 11.
they're trained to not react emotionally
but they still have emotions and they're
passionate about protecting the
passengers on the airplane because
without that we don't have a business
not only because we have our bodies on
that airplane too but you know when you
when you have your family traveling you
hand them over to me literally and
metaphorically you're saying this is my
life treasure please take care of it
[Music]
my guest today is captain dennis tager
who is himself a pilot 34 years i think
six years with the air force 29 years
with american airlines at 34 35 years he
flies right now as a pilot and at the
same time he's also the spokesperson for
apas allied pilots association a union
that represents 15 000 american airlines
pilots i believe it's the largest
independent pilots union in the world
with that being said dennis thank you so
much for being a guest on valuetainment
oh thank you it's an honor to be here
and uh you nailed it uh that's exactly
what we do and who we are well the
audience doesn't know i did that 78
times so i appreciate you for being nice
hey you know they they say i don't fear
a man who knows 10 000 kicks i fear the
man who knows one kicks kick and
practice it 10 000 times so um
yeah that that philosopher's name what
was it bruce lee right he's a great
philosopher well done uh yeah
philosopher and and uh uh yeah wow well
i surrender
so i surrender to you
because i have some questions i want
your help to see uh i've seen you speak
on what happened with boeing a couple
years ago when they didn't want to
disclose all the information on the
challenges they were facing i thought it
was with the 7 47 it was i don't know if
it was 7 37 or 7 30 7 match 7 37 and you
kind of called them out directly in a
respectful way because you're saying
look these are still good planes we
trust flying and we put our families on
there but you have to trust us on the
information and then at the same time i
see all the time on msnbc when you get
up there you talk about are americans
back flying etc etc so i have some
questions i'll go through my series of
questions and then anything else you
feel about where we are today i think
it's good for the audience to hear as
well so why don't we start off with 18
months ago we are uh
february of 2020 okay
in february 2020 we're still flying
things are normal march april may you
know we're getting a little bit more
nervous travel slows down
walk me through where we are today
compared to six months ago compared to
12 months ago in regards to americans
feeling comfortable traveling again
it's uh
night and day night being when when
things just shut down um and now coming
into that we actually at the apa um our
president and our experts at the time in
january well we don't relish the idea of
taking on legal action uh on behalf of
our membership against our company but
they wanted to continue flying into
china and we had boots on the ground
knowledge that this virus was was going
like crazy over there and we did not
want to be the vessel that transmitted
that virus back here into the u.s so
we very publicly and i was on cnbc said
they've got to cease this flying and and
there were commercial interests involved
we understand that
even they even disclosed actually in a
new york times article later american
airlines said well we thought china was
just a blip well it wasn't a blip so
this goes to our line they were on
record saying that this goes to our our
core mission as it would be as
professional pilots is that we're going
to put our passenger safety and security
first no matter what the commercial
interests are because commercial
interests will not survive unless you
provide that in the aviation business so
uh we they they did cease fine they
fought us a bit they even started to
bifurcate out hong kong a little saying
well it's a a separate area it's not an
island but long story short yeah we we
called them out and this is part of a
safety culture i know you and i spoke of
a little bit earlier but this is really
important is this radical transparency
is so important especially when the
consequences are so uh intense in in in
flying
um so
obviously the the the virus started to
spread rapidly and we saw um a lot of
good people even from from our
leadership here in the u.s to the
airlines trying to figure out okay how
do we contain this uh what do we know
about it and and it's
it's sadly i say it ironically laughable
some of the things that we would heard
even from our medical experts at the
company saying hey this is just like the
flu
it it doesn't spread easily
it turns out you know they were wrong
about that and we've learned many things
about this virus um but what we've
landed on
is that when when we take on certain
uh precautions we can help mitigate that
and i see a while using the the hand oh
you still i mean i got it everywhere
nowadays
my brain went right to it i i i hear you
and i i i smiled that because no
hypnotism you're hypnotizing me right
now to say wipe your hands
that's it suggestive power so
uh that being said though but you know
that's interesting because that just
exhibits how natural it is for us now i
don't like wearing the mask of course
it's uncomfortable in the whole nine
yards but hey those are the rules so
that's what we do we did have to fight
for a time to
wit with our and i had safe to fight we
had to compel our our airlines to say
hey look this may be the best thing to
do and even if you don't believe that
the the virus was was that critical or
that severe
back then or even today the bottom line
was it gave people some level of comfort
that if i do have to fly this may help
and it did and the airflow in the
airplane unlike the office and the home
that i sit in in the office you're in
that airflow is massive in there so
those types of things that boeing was
talking about our airlines were talking
about and our government president trump
were talking about in the department of
transportation that's the stakeholder
culture that comes together and says
yeah we had difference of opinion here
now we've all learned something where
can we land at a consensus so that
business and life can continue through
this struggle not go back to the way we
were during that time but to just like
your prior military on prior military
what can we contain and maintain safe
for our troops um and uh and that's what
we did and we did it sometimes as a
stakeholder who was yelling at the
rooftop saying no this is not right and
here's why and we use always we try to
use
we try to emulate i try to emulate our
union emulates where our pilots are
they're balanced men and women they're
logical uh they're they're trained to
not react emotionally but they still
have emotions and they're
passionate about protecting the
passengers on the airplane because
without that we don't have a business
yeah so so walk me through you know many
of us heard about it we read about it
but we don't really know what it looks
like it looks like so for example
you know uh margins profit margins and
airlines is one of the lowest out of all
the industries so there's not a lot of
money and everybody's kind of worshipper
we're cheaper we're cheaper so
everyone's trying to figure out
who to be minus spirit airlines but for
the most part everybody's trying to
figure out what they're going to be what
game they're going to be playing
so then buffett comes out and he says
hey i own 10 to 11 and delta american
united i'm gonna sell all of those
shares i was like a if that guy sells
what's he saying to the world what does
he know that the rest of us don't have
right
how bad did it get at one point for
pilots and flight attendants who don't
have a job
and these airlines that are in the break
of
bankruptcy what were pilots doing during
that time who maybe didn't have money
saved
to
be able to survive that three six nine
month period where there's not a lot of
traffic
well that's a great point and and thank
god our elected officials understood the
importance of the infrastructure of the
airline business because everybody knew
that this was a crisis it hit us really
hard american we had uniquely more debt
than others because we had bought a
bunch of airplanes that we needed to buy
others would be buying them now and uh a
various infrastructure post-merger
so we walked in with that um yeah the
margins are very tight but the federal
government identified and under
president trump and bipartisan this was
passed
investment packages we call them
investment because it was an investment
in the employees so that they would be
there for the recovery and sure there
were some other loans that were written
with some uh um uh i forget the term but
basically a stock under right so that
that that our taxpayer was accommodated
for this loan so that saved the airline
infrastructure which is a huge
foundation of our country's uh business
infrastructure so
fortunately our we work closely with our
management team and this is where you
know there's a stereotype of unions oh
they're always battling management men
is doing the other thing it's all about
cost well actually no we look at it in a
different way now it's a modernized uh
union perspective it's sort of
asymmetric we're as interested in the
business being wildly successful as our
management teams are we're investors in
our very own airline so we understand it
we don't we don't look at it through the
the narrow uh the straw of hey it's just
labor whatever i can get paid i'll get
paid we we sign up for the our we stay
i'm here 30 about 30 years and that's
one place you go and you stay so when
that happened though the federal
government did step up used our taxpayer
money to ensure that the airlines were
ready to roll and they provided actually
payroll support through this and a
couple of cycles so that prevented
thousands of pilots in particular from
being laid off and as you know from from
high training events uh both in military
and business you can't just say hey get
back to work so that that stopped that
huge cycle of upswing training that
would have happened which would have
muted this recovery this summer and
would have probably uh bled into other
businesses from the hotel side to just
the morale of the country um yeah it's a
private business that's publicly held
but it's a symbol of the strength of our
country um so what pilots did we took
some leaves we took some of our pilots
wanted they have a businesses on the
side or their their spouse works they
took um about a
a 60 of their of their normal pay and
said i'll take a leave and i'll keep
trained up other pots took early
retirements a package was provided for
them so they would get some benefits for
a couple years until the mandatory
retirement so a lot of outside the box
thinking was done to preserve
and sustain the airline and when the
federal government came in that was the
um
more than a lifeline that was keeping
the infrastructure settled so that this
summer came along and while we were
challenged this summer uniquely at
american
um we would have been nowhere near this
recovery this summer if that had not
been done so uh
a long way to say
a
deep thank you to all involved and uh in
order for our country to thrive our
businesses have to survive and thrive so
that's what happened in this and and now
we're moving forward from that you i
don't know many spokes
person or spokespeople for unions who
see it from your point of view it's
always let me gouge the business owner
for as much as possible i don't care
what uh it costs to get profits from him
to get into the
individuals members of the union so
kudos to you because you seem very
balanced and reasonable on both sides if
you were a politician you'd be a
statesman that's fighting for both sides
realizing there's numbers in it but you
also process it accordingly if for the
people that
took a hit the 60 the early retirement
or the flight attendant what percentage
of the people that didn't retire came
back
what percentage of people just move down
to different industries different jobs
a very small amount speaking to the
pilots we had a few pilots that went on
to um maybe work for a package carrier
but we're talking single-digit numbers
so uh
they came back i mean it's it's a it's a
wonderful career you gotta fight for it
um just like any business you know you
fight for your interests you uh
uh and you talked about this different
way of looking it's not just me it's our
union i mean we you 12 years ago when i
started involved in union business i
said i think we can do this a different
way and had other partners in that and
one of them was to reach out to the
people who own the company which are
investors and so we reached out i
literally had a
cold call to a sell side analyst and
said hey i'm with the union i wanted to
connect with you and these are analysts
that write notes on the investment
perspective they talk to the buy side
all the investment uh
institutional investors
and it's it's at the heartbeat of what
makes a business run a publicly held one
so we wanted to to call them not to rant
at them about hey i'm a union guy and
here's the deal we wanted to understand
the business better and get their
perspective and um sometimes we use that
to our advantage and most importantly
though we have a saying at the union is
if you're not at the table you might be
on the menu
and that's one place we don't want to be
so we always insist on being at the
table and we don't yell to get at the
table we we find a way to be functional
partners in this
rationally thinking and it paid off when
american airlines went into bankruptcy
and another air carrier u.s air their
management team senior management team
wanted to come in and construct do a
reconstruction plan
an exit plan and involve the merger we
were right there at the table as a
matter of fact
the president of that airline scott
kirby is now the ceo of united airlines
asked for a private meeting in new york
just like the movies i'm i'm just a
pilot and i'm i don't own a business but
it was just like you'd imagine let's
meet and i went out with the president
of the union at the time met in a new
york restaurant in the back
and he pulled out an envelope to talk
about his vision for a merger of the two
airlines while we were in bankruptcy
and that was the beginning of the new
american airlines and it literally was a
sit down with two leaders i was there as
some of the expert in the knowledge of
the networks and they talked about
synergy they talked about here's how
much money that we can add to whatever
deal you get i i'm not afraid to talk
about the details because it was just
like any other business detail here are
the opportunities and here's what you
would be uh the reward for it
and just like any business deal our
president time said why not double that
and it turned out to be three times that
because the value of the deal with
functional partners and we went out and
pitched it hard
actually increased so it was
how many wins can you count it was a
win-win-win old equity got paid in full
unprecedented bankruptcy and i apologize
for digressing but it's very exciting
part of the aviation business you know
it's not just airflow over the wing that
makes the airplane fly its money flow
over the wing they've got to come
together and that can be success for
everybody involved it's not just a dream
we saw it happen and we'll continue to
push for it yeah that's uh that's that's
very impressive to hear about that part
as well there was a part that you were
pretty competitive against other
airlines i'm curious is the world you're
in a pretty competitive world where you
are protective of american airlines or
is it more of a fraternity where it
doesn't matter if you're delta united
you know southwest we all work together
as a fraternity what's what's your role
like because i'm assuming like you know
how you're an air force i'm an army
marines navy were typically they put
marines in army base next to each other
yes we both are fighting for red white
and blue but you're marine i'm army i
see you at the bar we're getting into a
fistfight i don't see pilots getting
into fist fights but is it is it a
pretty competitive environment or no
oh absolutely oh gosh absolutely and
your your metaphor using the military is
dead on i was going to go to that and
while you described it i said you know
pick the nfl you know look at those
players they go out there and and they
battle they compete when the game's done
they go hey good to go i might see on my
team later we don't change that much in
airline business but oh absolutely it's
and you know let's be blunt about it
it's more fun that way if you're not
fighting for your your company then what
the hell are you here for
um so but it doesn't mean that hey i
know that you're fighting for yours and
we do we have meetings we talk with our
union brothers and sisters and they go
hey man it was kind of rough on us over
there i go yeah we'll get your operation
fixed and and we'll roll and but we also
recognize that that there is a ladder
there's pattern bargaining for that you
know and people talk about pattern
bargaining or bargaining negotiating a
table those are business deals that's
all they are sure and they can pro they
can enhance a relationship uh they
develop trust
and uh you live up to it so it's
it's fraternal in a sense and what we do
just like in the military we're counting
on each other to each we have each
other's backs but even in business
you know just because you may not have a
major accident happen this is someone's
livelihood they're paying for their
family's future in the whole nine yards
so um knowing and identifying that and
connecting to it but still being a
shrewd and firm business uh businessman
or woman is um that's aviation i mean
we're we're not negotiating on a flight
deck but we have a set agreement of
procedures and protocol
and um
there's a chain of command and there's
leveraging of ideas
uh but
that's why i love the business i i love
everything about it it's very obvious i
mean your passion and your and your
conviction is definitely felt even
through zoom here it's felt
uh
question i'm an executive platinum
myself with american airlines i've flown
with airlines thank you yeah i'm an
american airline guy i was with delta
before i was with united and i said nope
i'm going american and i've stayed with
american
so walk me through
uh you know like for me i'm the paranoid
guy i go to restaurants i look at
people's nails i'm like oh my gosh he's
not gonna deliver my food for me i get
up and walk out i'm that weird guy right
like i'm like if this guy has too much
hair or let's just say too much sweat
here i can't have you carry my food i
get a little bit nervous about it
because of my wiring now you can call me
a lot of different words a lot of
different doctors can put categories on
me they're probably all right but let's
set that part aside
how do i trust right now i'm a traveler
and say i've had kobe before and i'm
like you know what didn't kill me but it
sucks flat out this thing sucks i didn't
i had it myself last earlier this year
wasn't fun right
uh emma you know as did i yeah i also
okay so for me it wasn't the taste it
wasn't the breathing for me i lost 24
pounds within three weeks i couldn't eat
anything i mean it was a complete
different game so and i stayed positive
for like four weeks anyways going back
to it somebody wants to travel they're
like look
i want to travel but what do you guys do
in between
flights for me to know that it's clean
don't get me wrong i want to bring my
own wipe and i'm going to do my own
thing but what is american airlines
instructed to do between flights for the
new you know passenger to come in and
say listen this place is going to be
clean like almost like switching a hotel
room somebody stays
before you do what is the protocol you
guys follow
well and
great question and by the way welcome to
the fraternity you have attention to
detail i do the same thing and that's
something that keeps us
safe in on the flight deck as well uh
and probably a very successful
businessman as i understand you are
um that being said what can passengers
count on well we've learned a lot about
the virus you know at first and and we
still american has a deep cleaning in
between flights um that it does and an
even deeper one at night um but we have
learned about the virus you remember
there was a time where yes we were
sprained on everything and and they
still are and they run various lighting
through the airplane but we've learned
that the the virus isn't as uh easy to
pick up off of inanimate objects doesn't
mean they've stopped the behavior but
the most important thing on the airplane
is that airflow is that airflow that
airflow changes over and i had i've lost
the memory of how many times per per uh
hour a minute but it's extraordinary
it's at least 10 times more than your
office so and we're in charge of that we
have the apu that's that's the amount of
air going through while you're on the
ground uh or while the engines are
running so it's a massive flow your hair
may not be blowing around but i can
assure you that that airflow is
happening like this so that is actually
near the level of the the filters we
have on the recirculating part are at
the same level the hepa level of a
surgery room and we're just lucky that
it was designed that way originally so
um the irony is the airplane is is
actually one of the safer places to be
around a group of people so but you know
we didn't take that as a hey so we don't
need masks that was part of the protocol
if it wasn't just something else made
someone feel more comfortable it
actually worked you can debate that all
day long yeah but when we started that
people started to fly and come back and
they didn't have one case that they
could trace back to oh there was a
massive spread on an airplane and
believe me we were holding our breath on
that no pun intended about please let
this not happen on this airplane because
i was out there flying i remember going
out to new york and we had like four or
five people ended up talking with them a
couple doctors and some nurses going out
there to do their work
walking through the airport when it was
empty i remember walking through miami
doing a piece with abc saying
very uncomfortable uh and now i have to
wait in line for
a starbucks
thank you
it's it's it's night and day so um so
the bottom line your your awareness of
your surroundings
and what's being done is important
because we want to assure especially uh
passengers customers like yourself an
executive that we've got your back on
this and uh as pilots
uh we're watching that too we don't just
get through the cockpit door and go okay
that's all we're in charge of we're
making sure that okay was the airplane
taken care of hey it just came in from
a caribbean destination did it get its
full cleaning and our flight attendants
as well so um not only because we have
our bodies on that airplane too but you
know when you when you have your family
traveling you hand them over to me
literally and metaphorically you're
saying this is my life treasure please
take care of it and i have kids you can
damn sure bet that i'm going to do
everything in my power and not just from
a commercial sense but from the the
moral and and professional obligation i
have as a pilot the wings that are on my
chest are not just there for optics
they're they're tattooed on everything
we do
when's your birthday about having a
guess of what month your birthday is and
i'm just curious when is your birthday
are we exchanging gifts okay it is uh
december 28th
you're a capricorn interesting i am well
and
i i wish i could have a deeper
conversation anything that means
i i i'm intrigued though i
i feel compelled to ask what's your sign
but that could get weird
so
but
it's my weird math side that i try to
see if there's any connections between
personalities of you know how the
individual is organized systematic you
know detail or a little bit more
personality not paying attention to
details anyway that's just my own thing
well you know what i've been i've been
accused of being a deeply seated
capricorn so i know what that means and
yeah
i'll embrace that if it kept me alive
that's great if it uh you know made for
a boring night i'm sorry but i i i think
i would want to have you as a pilot and
i'm okay with that so you you capital
that's right by the way i i did get
furloughed from american airlines in the
90s got a year on and it happened back
in the day uh you know cycles happen
and i i'm a school teacher by education
um and i taught in the air force of
course flying uh but um uh i taught for
three years as a high school junior high
school math teacher until flying came
back around so uh
um yeah numbers uh but numbers that
connect to human beings and just like
you referenced this the boeing 737 max
those tragedies those two aircraft and
the reasons that it happened
connecting that story
um versus pilots we wanted to process it
why didn't you tell us this was on the
airplane and all the things that many
people are aware of
but being able to tell that story in a
way that that um someone couldn't come
along like going say hey it's very
complicated there's a lot of issues it's
not that complicated let me explain so
the airplane has this it does that and
here's why we didn't know about it
that important connection with other
human beings to say yeah it looks like a
magical thing this pilot all these knobs
and all that but we can get it down to
look it's it's pretty basic here um so
um
that
the trait as it is in any business your
ability to convey what you do or what
your product is or how this can enhance
uh what your business is doing um is is
is key i mean it's communication it's
relationships
i totally agree i agree with that uh
going back to a couple things in regards
to
uh travel with
uh where we currently are so
uh i saw a survey the other day on cnn
it said 63 percent of americans believe
a vaccination uh passports ought to be
mandated right travel now i'm not asking
your opinion on that what i'm asking you
is
is there anything you have as being a
spokesperson of a union 15 000 members
where it is leading towards a direction
where we're probably going to see all
the major airlines
wanting to see a passport when we get on
a flight or you're saying i don't know
if that's going to happen
well we're reviewing the news changes
all the time particularly what we're
focused on is our we have some airlines
i think united said all employees have
to get vaccinated and
we we have some 65 of our pilots are
vaccinated i'm vaccinated i happen to
believe it worked for my family but we
have affirmed that it's we believe it's
a personal choice and our ceo doug
parker even affirmed that the other day
saying that
we we we haven't we actually have a
letter of agreement that will will
compensate you for getting the shot or
get you off the flying after you when
you recover from the shot there's 48
hours of pilot should not fly so um
that's where we are at american as far
as our passengers and what they're going
to need to travel you know we just want
to make sure they're safe we just
actually had news there's a smaller
country down in south america the name
escapes me who just the other day said
starting on x date crew members coming
in will have to be vaccinated so now
we're going through the uh those pilots
who have those trips at the moment uh
being pulled off those trips if they're
not vaccinated so um
you know it's a it's a new space um but
we can't forget who we are regardless of
your opinion and as a union we represent
the the 14 to 15 000 pilots each of them
have a personal choice on the vaccine
and our job is to advocate for whether
you want to get it or you choose to make
that decision otherwise
and ensure it's terms of employment
and you have to talk with the union
about how they would be executed so as
far as passengers go you know i'm going
to speak from a business side anything
that gets people to fly
and they want to fly and they feel safe
let it roll that is not an affirmation
of a vaccine passport but we want people
to feel safe and comfortable traveling
and um
you know whatever ideas are out there
we're going to course process them but
uh you know we may have an opinion on
them or not on that one we're just going
to let the folks that have the authority
to to run through it but you know what
business ain't easy anybody who thinks
that you know run a business
it might be if you're just
making something that doesn't involve
people but everything we make involves
people so welcome to the nfl yeah no no
no question about that maybe even bigger
than the nfl because you guys are you
don't play 16 games you you're playing
uh uh
hundreds of games on a daily basis so
it's a completely different
uh a world you're only asked because i
wonder
you know i mean no matter what you
choose you're going to piss off an
audience right you're going to be like
well we're going to do this we're going
to well we're not going to why don't you
be responsible get everybody vaccinated
why are you doing it let me kind of
choose my own stuff so
that's the challenge of being a
capitalist running a business you gotta
make the decision and at the same time
leave the freedom but sometimes the
government may come in and say hey you
guys gotta what was the story with delta
saying 300 300 per employee that's not
vaccinated because it's costing them 5
500 of hospitals some number like that i
said i know
i i i know we saw that up to 200 or 300
more per month for their medical if
they're not vaccinated that's the delta
choice um you know to to to maybe fight
the delta variant i know they don't like
to align those things but hey the
alphabet's the alphabet but uh um that's
not being talked of at american airlines
um you know so
uh sometimes
outside the box thinking um well will
this they'll make their choice but that
you know that is that is the challenge
in this and yeah you know you know the
the sign of any good deal is when both
sides feel like they didn't get just the
perfect deal right um
and and uh
it's
it's very it's very emotional it should
be this is about our lives it's not just
about business and um it's it's you know
there's one thing saying oh i respect
both sides but now show me that you
respect both sides that's the key yeah
it's tough it's tough because i see that
i'm like well that's kind of weird to
set that up
when it comes down to uh uh
career-wise like a choice of do you know
the margins of airlines i hear three and
a half percent you do you know what the
margins are like what kind of money
they're making because the numbers seem
very
small almost like minuscule profits
these airlines are making
oh yeah i mean the the pre-tax profit
margin is is very very thin
it's a very cash flow intensive uh
business enterprise no doubt about it um
but i mean now i think we might hit some
positive uh pre-tax margins here in the
third quarter you know the delta variant
didn't help but it's been negative for
years but even in the the best of times
they're in the upper single digits low
double digits um and they're bragging on
it so you know when we went through this
merger and it was like the last major
merger more or less they talked about
rationalizing the space and a re-rate on
the space you know talking with
investors and all um
and that not a pipe dream it's certainly
more stable a little more like rail but
not like it at all it's a it's a
a pretty dynamic space to be invested as
you mentioned warren buffett you know
years ago
he said uh all right forget the quip it
was
very funny it's not how do you make a a
million dollars and there was something
to do about besting in airlines and was
the opposite of what you think but it's
um it's a tough space
um and it's a narrow margin
but it does have levels of profitability
i mean american on alone forget the
proportional basis was five to six
billion dollars of pre-tax profits so
um and if you look at the brand and the
value of the brand and you wonder okay
that's a pretty narrow margin let's say
forget the raw dollars if you look at
the value of the brand when they went
through when we went through this
darkest of time all the airlines started
trying to generate private capital uh
loans for their uh frequent flyer mile
program and they did billions of dollars
18 billion on american airlines and then
they went a step further in an area that
i don't understand although we've spoken
with the experts who actually formulate
these deals of actually generating
capital uh loans off of your brand that
may be your space but i i don't
understand that you know i'm more of a
touch feel uh sort of a guy but
you can generate how many billion
dollars just on your brand that's
important to us because your brand is us
your brand is what we do for people
safely carrying them making you want to
be an executive
a platinum member at american airlines
so
um they all connect if you just open
your mind whether it be as an employee a
pilot a union or a business partner to
what is important to your success i can
influence that
um you know i i can't make you do
something but i can make you wish you
did that's not a threat that's a help me
help you plea that makes sense that
makes sense i have two other questions
for you before we wrap up one of them is
uh in regards to 911 because i know
you've spoken about that before but i'll
come back to that here in a minute to
wrap up the interview with
uh
private jets i uh chartered the uh you
know the last couple weeks i went all
over the place four different flights
and i'm going back and forth and i've
talked to one of the guys who bought
this plane 11 million dollars and he was
a hedge fund guy from greenwich he said
he ends up buying this i said so tell me
what business is like
said listen i'm not gonna lie to you we
need more jets right now because we are
so swamped right
okay
so
that business is taking off right now
because some people if they can afford
it they'd much rather spend the money to
have to
fly uh uh you know private then have to
fly commercial get it is that going to
affect your business dramatically
obviously not i'm looking at the tsa the
numbers are like 1.662
as of yesterday versus one point nine
four three three hundred thousand uh
down it's maybe a fifteen percent number
and if we look at the day before two
million twenty five thousand travelers
on september six
last year same uh 2019
september 6 was 2.292 so it's only like
a 200 000. again 10
so
what what do you see happening to the
private jet charter business will that
affect anything with the commercial side
and if not
what do you see happening in the middle
is there something going to the middle
because it's like it almost looks like
travel is you either buy a i don't know
you either buy a
you know a uh
forty thousand dollar sedan
and then it goes boom ferrari like
they're in the in the travel world
there's not yeah you can say first class
fine amg but there's not like you go
from 40 to you know
120 000 or 180 000
do you guys see something as a
competitor coming up that's in the
middle between you and charter
that'd be nice i mean that's that's
management's marketing uh skills and and
we watch that because you talked about
those passenger numbers and we're elated
to see that there's another side of it
as a business uh professional you know
there's yield what are you able to
charge for those tickets you know what's
the demand like and and and that's
really what's crushing is still holding
back the earnings is is that ability to
charge just the right amount for the
ticket but uh um where's that middle
ground that's something that that even
working with our flight attendants
because it's the quality of the product
and you're right all right i'm in this
beautiful first class seat on this very
long flight uh what else is it providing
me versus the amount of money it cost me
so you know that is going to be a
challenge and you know our corporate
pilots we know that uh
the netjet guys we work they have a
union there too uh is part of a
subsidiary of warren buffett's uh uh
holdings
um so we talk with them we know their
clientele and what they're looking for
is fractional ownership or as you
discussed it um but i i think we want
that business to grow if that business
grows that means people who make a very
healthy sum of money are able to support
that need that they have and that just
feeds into the pilot profession more
jets flying
and that's something we want to see
happen do we want do we not want those
folks on our airplane no we want them on
airplane too but there's got to be
a a common ground that's met and it's
going to be met by the supply and the
demand and you know there's there's one
thing that's for certain if people don't
have the money to spend on flying they
won't fly if they don't want to fly i
can't fly whether it's at the top ceo
that buys an uh you know a multi-million
dollar jet so that he or she can go
wherever they need to go on their team
and that pilot's flying it that's
another one of us up there so
um we want to be supportive of that and
uh
you know i'll be blunt the wealthier
people are the better it is because they
can take on those other uh prospects
and on the commercial side those
businesses are flourishing and growing
they're gonna have people that will fly
on us that need to fly on us even in
those first class seats so bring it on
success business success leads the
business flying and that leads to our
success the business traveler is the
most profitable side for us and leisure
has gotten us through this domestic side
right here but man oh man you've got to
accommodate that business traveler and
and lure them in not only with words but
with real value
and we're part of that and we're proud
to be that part yeah i mean listen again
union spokesperson who supports
capitalism gotta love it who says
let the wealthy get wealthier so we can
keep getting more business because you
you feel it on your end let's talk about
911.
i started working on morgan stanley dean
witter a day before 9 11. my first day
was 9 10 it was a monday so my 20-year
anniversary is coming up in the next
what is today eight in two days right
two days it'll be 20 years that i've
been in the financial industry day one
everything is good
day two tuesday morning 6 30 california
pacific standard time first plane then
we saw second plane hit live it was
morgan stanley dean witter's
headquarters 3 600 employees in world
trade center a complete obviously
travesty
uh that took place
fast forward to today i got the question
i'd like you to unpack this and i think
you can probably give the technical
aspect of this on one end is
so afghanistan and what just happened
right now with the taliban and
afghanistan 75 i don't need to tell you
the numbers you know the numbers 83
billion dollars of equipment left there
some of the stuff we re deactivated so
they don't have access to but it's not a
lot of it they got plenty of stuff right
and they're getting stronger it becomes
a recruiting center for them
many experts you'll talk to they say the
chances of another attack increase
these are folks who are military you
know they're saying well we have to be
careful we have to play
from the standpoint of paranoia
one from your perspective how much
how tougher is it today
for a person to
do another uh
911 based on we all know i think tsa
came out in november of oath uh
is when president bush two months later
started tsa we didn't have tsa before
november i don't know the exact dates
but i think it was november 01 and then
everything changed prior to that
security was faster etc etc
how much more confident are you that an
event like that cannot happen and how
strict is the training today
to
increase the level of awareness to make
sure there's the chances of that ever
happening to it is like zero to none
two questions for you i'm curious to
hear your thoughts great questions and
uh it's not paranoia if there's a threat
out there so uh not to awfulize it but
as pilots were always thinking about the
next engine failure and not like i hope
it doesn't happen uh it's when it
happens here's what we're gonna do so
that this the the the startle effect the
shock and awe is not there uh you know
and you mentioned 911 i i'm i'm wearing
a pin here which is the 20th
commemoration from our union on it our
union's very involved in that of course
we lost you know brothers and sisters in
that and our country was ripped apart
the globe was ripped apart um so as far
as that happening again
i'm confident that there are barriers to
prevent it as much as possible
um but
you always strive for perfection we
strive for never a crash again on any
airplane knowing that at some point it's
probably going to happen but you go for
perfection and so you get to a point
that's really hitting at the heartbeat
of something on this 20th anniversary
and my heart goes out to you because you
your fellow workers just like mine were
murdered on that day and that could have
been you in that building it's just a
question of geography so uh it hits at
us hard but
one of the areas that that has enraged
us and fortunately we have bipartisan
bill right now that provides for a a
second barrier prior to the cockpit door
that cockpit door is good it has been
passed
george bush uh our president made sure
that door is reinforced we have
procedures of course we have federal air
marshals on airplanes we have uh pilots
who are armed on the aircraft um the
door we have procedures i can't get into
the all the procedures but it's a whole
different way at looking at aircraft
security and it doesn't take a genius to
figure out that at all costs you protect
that aircraft because we will not turn
this airplane into a weapon
so that legislation i mentioned
is for second barriers to think that 20
years after 9 11 we're talking about
getting a second barrier and what it's
for is to ensure that there's one more
barrier in front of that door that's a
good door but you see we have
physiological breaks no mystery or
secret to anybody on a long flight we do
have to come out once in a while we're
very structured in that but we need that
barrier to provide one more bit of time
for us because you know seconds matter
if someone was to approach that door
whether it be an unruly passenger who
just wasn't well or someone who had
nefarious intent and it was a plot and
or other people this is not meant to
scare you this is meant to let you know
that we're thinking about this every
minute of every flight and when we get a
call about a disturbance in the back
my brain immediately goes to who is
wants to do harm beyond just that area
and it's just something bigger and
grander and it's a saying if you see
something say something if we hear
something we start thinking that way
it's not paranoia if the
potential threats there it's just like
anything else you want your police
officers and or your military to be
ready to protect you and to think the
worst case scenario until they
de-escalate and realize okay you're
secure
that's the passion that we have and we
need
the rest of congress to step up
and support this bill and and get it
through so that i'm not sitting here
20 years from now or my daughter who's
in flying talking about how we're still
trying to get this through and you know
unfortunately one of the adversaries of
this original legislation some time ago
that watered it down
to being only new new airplanes and not
one airplane has this barrier on it
right now
unfortunately was our airlines as a
lobby group and aircraft manufacturers
citing that the cost of it well i tell
you the cost of this this system which
is not very complex
but is very effective is about the cost
of a seat back entertainment center that
someone's staring at so you can't afford
to not do this it's it's it's about not
only protecting
my passengers my airline
but my country and the globe get it done
and get moving we're ready now back us
up you need uh you need to have our back
on this what would this do again what
would this do this would do what it is
is you have the flight deck door yeah
this would be another barrier prior to
the door that could be opened and closed
and what it does
one of the primary things on of course
it provides a level of protection even
if that door is closed right
because you know
some of our our most effective defenders
of the flight deck are
my fellow passengers you know you've
seen those stories even after 9 11. i
flew i was laying over in albany new
york during 9 11 watching the second
crash thinking
what is happening here um
so
and and getting on the airplane right
after that with passengers who looked at
me not just eye to eye but soul to soul
we good captain yes we are counting on
you yes we are we're good to go but that
gives us some time with that door closed
when we take physiological breaks
there's a short moment of time that that
door is open this will provide another
layer of barrier and you know anybody
who flies sees it there's levels of
barriers we have people we have other
things there that that slow that down
but why wouldn't you for the small price
that it is
buy me another 30 seconds another minute
and
it just makes no sense and uh maybe just
people fell asleep but you know what
they're awake now we have bipartisan
support on it so it's sad that on the
20th anniversary i have to even talk
about this but
out of respect for those we lost and the
men and women that fought terrorism and
continue to fight it across the globe we
owe it to them we owe it to them and
their kids to get this done today not in
20 years but get it done in 20 minutes
now captain taters is there a place to
see this bill or no where if somebody
wants to learn more about this bill what
would they read about it well then you
can go to the the public site of apa
which is alliedpilots.org
alliedpilots.org and we actually have
thanks for bringing that up because
they'll be led right to a a picture of a
young man who's a pilot for us and
that's tom mcginnis jr his dad was uh
killed on 9 11 on one of the aircraft he
was the first pilot that american
airlines hired after the 911 lull in
hiring and they did it intentionally and
purposely and i know tommy's based in
chicago matter of fact i think i have a
flight schedule with him uh later in the
month um a good man and he was uh
uh
generous enough to do in a one-minute
interview
speech just basically say get this for
us um and uh you know he's he's much
younger man than me but a role model to
me um i don't know that i could have
done that if i'd lost my dad i i might
go into a more closed position but uh
it's real it's connected to people and
you have a connection to it and
everybody
listening probably has some layer of
connection to it so it's our history we
don't run from it we don't forget but we
make a solemn promise to never again and
we do that together regardless of
countries or political affiliation um
you know i i'm sorry to go into a rant
but no no no i'm listening it's it's i
told you i'll catch you
i watch i watch a handful of your
interviews and when i see you you the
way
you know truth cuts through everything
you cut through everything and there is
no
one side or the other you're
straight forward and and nobody feels
like you're taken aside and i applaud
you for that uh we need more leaders
like you who deliver their message in
the manner that you do
because it allows us to sit there and
decipher through the bs that's out there
and say look this makes sense i think
this makes sense i think this makes
sense i don't know about this i think
this is right so we're going to put i'm
on the website we're on
alliedpilots.org we're going to put the
link below both in the description and
the comment section for folks to be able
to find it captain dennis tajer i got to
tell you i had a blast having you on
today this is an entrepreneur channel
and i know we talked about that briefly
off camera
but the entrepreneurs travel a lot and
they wanted this is a big part of their
lives we spent a lot of time on planes
we spent a lot of time going to places
and it's very important for us to know
that
uh the direction of your industry is
going and you gave us a lot of insight i
appreciate you for it
it's been an honor thank you anytime
again call on call on us and we'll be
there appreciate it it definitely won't
be the last time thank you
take care sir take care
i don't know about you but i learned a
lot about what's going on today in
travel and i'm probably gonna end up
having him back because i really enjoyed
the way captain dennis tager processes
issues an event that comes up we're
definitely going to bring him back if
you liked it smash thumbs up i got one
other video that i think you're going to
enjoy it's a video i did maybe five six
years ago titled 19 lessons
of what i learned when i was in the army
if you've never seen a click over here
to watch it take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]